bonjour et avec des mouvements bonjour
il ya quelques jours la cour
constitutionnelle de karlsruhe qui est
l'équivalent allemand de notre conseil
constitutionnel après une décision qui
pour vous est très importante
laquelle alors il faut bien comprendre
que la cour constitutionnelle de
karlsruhe n'est pas l'équivalent du
conseil constitionnel je je je joue sur
les mots vous allez comprendre pourquoi
c'est beaucoup plus important que la
cour que le conseil constitionnel les
allemands se vivent depuis 45 avec le
tas après le traumatisme icariens après
le les rédactions de la leur
constitution par les américains voyez
comme un archétype de l'état de droit
nous on est plutôt une monarchie
républicaine qui met un peu de
gouvernement des juges dans des
institutions voyez verticale c'est ce
n'est pas leur cas c'est très important
pour eux c'est devenu vous savez vous
qu'on sauve et c'est ce n'est pas un
hasard si c'est un allemand
habermas qui a parlé de patriotisme
constitutionnel c'est ton parenthèse que
je crois important pour bien expliquer
en quoi cette décision est un coup de
tonnerre
c'est une c'est une affaire qui remonte
à 2015 vous souvenez quand mario draghi
le patron d'alors de la banque centrale
européenne a s'est sorti du cadre des
traités a sorti la banque centrale
européenne du cadre des traités pour
pour pour prêter aux états vous savez
que c'est interdit par les institutions
de la banque centrale européenne et de
la zone euro la fameuse indépendance de
la banque centrale fallait donc la
banque centrale ne doit pas financer les
états or après la crise de 2008 et la
crise grecque pour sauver l'euro mario
draghi est sorti de ce2 ce2 ce cadre là
et il y à une bataille entre la cour
européenne de caracalla cour
constitutionnelle de karlsruhe qui dit
c'est pas possible c'est c'est pas
normal c'est hors de toute
proportionnelle it est nécessaire et la
cour de justice européenne qui dit
maintenant ils ont très bien fait on
peut sortir des cadres des traités les
traités on s'en moque et ses ouailles et
pan
ce que dit la cour constitionnelle de
quatre ou deux choses
elle met deux claques en fait une claque
à la bce en lui disant tu es sorti des
traités et une autre claque encore plus
importante selon moi à la cour de
justice européenne en lui disant tu n'es
pas mon supérieur
il n'y a pas de hiérarchie des juges en
europe
nous ne sommes pas dans un régime
fédéral la cour de justice ne vaut que
par les délégations que lui donnent les
états nations comme les comme la
commission de bruxelles comme la bce
nous ne sommes pas dans un état fédéral
car la démocratie n'est qu'une ex
s'exerce que dans le cadre des nations
selon vous la décision de la cour de
karlsruhe mais en quelque sorte l'église
au milieu du village en réaffirmant la
supériorité du droit national des
constitutions de chaque pays sur le
droit européen
c'est d'ailleurs le droit français ne
dit pas autre chose
seulement les français ont pris
l'habitude à chaque fois qu'il y avait
un nouveau traité d'européens de
modifier leur constitution
voyez ça s'est réglé la question comme
ça on met en en accord mais les
allemands refusent ça parce que je vous
dis ils ont ils sacraliser la
constitution 1 pour des raisons
historiques que je vous ai dit et donc
là en plus il y à un désaccord de fond
entre les conceptions allemandes qui
sont qu' on ne doit pas la banque
centrale ne doit pas prêter aux états
parce que sinon il ya un risque
d'inflation et les conceptions des
autres en particulier de l'itanien
draghi et de son successeur madame
lagarde qui va faire pire encore qui va
prêter encore plus et encore plus au
pays les plus demandeurs c'est-à-dire
l'italie et accessoirement la france oui
alors qu'avant mario draghi qui est un
gros malin faisait semblant de respecter
une clé de répartition égale pour tous
les états à briller pour faire semblant
de ne pas croiser ne pas qu'on dise que
c'était pour aider l'italie
christine lagarde devant la gravité de
la crise d'aujourd'hui et fait pire
évidemment parce que voyez c'est on n'a
même plus les plus d'heures d'avant
c'est l'existence même de l'euro qui est
en jeu selon vous après cette décision
alors c'est exactement ça parce que vous
avez compris que la banque centrale à la
cour tensionnelle de castres où
contrairement à ce que disent d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens ne donnent aucune
injonction aux institutions européennes
elle donne des injonctions aux
gouvernements allemand et à la banque
centrale allemande et elle dit si dans
trois mois
la banque centrale européenne n'a pas
donné de justificatifs de justification
oui qui prouve que l a bien agi et ben
vous ne devez plus participer aux
procédures monétaire de la banque
centrale européenne ça veut dire que les
allemands
en clair ne rachète ne ne rachète plus
les dettes des états pour le compte de
la banque centrale européenne ça veut
dire vous avez bien compris vu que
l'allemagne et la puissance et la
principale puissance économique de la
zone euro c'est de dire la fin de la
zone euro ou alors ou alors les
allemands au nom de l'europe au nom de
la solidarité européenne au nom même de
leur intérêt dans la zone euro dit eh
ben moi je n'écoute pas la cour
constitionnelle de 4 secondes
mais dans ce cas là comme je voulais
expliqué au début c'est pour ça que je
voulais dit ça veut dire que madame
merkel remet en cause tout l'esprit des
institutions allemandes ou alors les
allemands disent eh bien puisque c'est
comme ça
la banque centrale européenne ne doit
pas faire voyez c'est ce qu'elle avait
prévu de faire c'est-à-dire ramasser dès
1750 milliards de dette
oui
et dans ce cas là ce sont les italiens
et les français qui explose parce que la
dette est devenue tellement importante
si la banque centrale européenne ne
ramassent pas les dettes françaises et
italiennes
alors là il ya le feu au lac et donc
c'est l'italie et la france qui devront
alors sortir de la zone euro pour
pouvoir se refinancer avec leurs banques
centrales nationales
donc soit l'allemagne sort soit là
l'italie et la france sorte oui
cc c'est pour vous dire que c'est
gravissime pour la zone euro là elle est
en danger devant merci eric zemmour